they surrendered our strength and turned  Afghanistan into the greatest  humiliation our country has ever had and  now we have a war between Russia and  Ukraine with potentially hundreds of  thousands of people dying that would  never have happened if our president  would never it was not even thinkable  number one the energy cost the price per  barrel was at forty dollars he can't  have a war he can't afford it at a  hundred dollars he can afford it the  election was rigged and stolen and now  our country is being destroyed I ran  twice I won twice and did much better  the second time than I did the first  getting Millions more votes in 2020 that  I got in 2016 and likewise getting more  votes than any sitting president in the  history of our country by far and now in  order to make our country successful and  safe and glorious  I will very very very probably do it  again okay